o pólo da avenida mais um vídeo e hoje
ensina como fazer uma boa e que andré
tem duas bolas de cabeça a bola de
cabeça não só para enfeitar a chegada da
engraçada
a gente tem bastante no circuito vamos
ensinar algo entre eles um instrutor que
o sinal só sejam tiverem podem sempre
comentava o carro terá também em o motor
é usar um tom caixa noção ou sair de
campo tocando muito anda a meter muita
força nos conselhos não ter eles podem
estar nos anos normais que você está em
casa uma vez que eu fiz uma pequena
caixa produção cá dentro que pode ser o
suficiente para que eu gostava ou
funciona o que não é o ideal é realizado
todo cachorro só enquanto agora vou
fazer um kena vou fazer porque a
construção por você acha que posso
passar
um gol logo logo
o cocô ró
o forró
tá
ae
efe